do you think it's better in 2020 to be a
black person or white person obviously
you can answer whatever you want
difficult because we're white so I
cannot have an opinion on a black person
like so how can I say like
oh yeah amazing because at the end of
the day like I think as I think we just
almost they got a privilege I I don't
really I don't think I could ever or
could ever say that or it's better than
that because I actually never lived in
the body of a black no I've never lived
in the body of a black person I cannot
tell you categorically whether it's
better to be white or black yeah can you
elaborate when you on what you when you
say that you have an inherent privilege
like can you can you go further into
that can you explain what you mean I
think I think like me I think like Tech
talk or like I think I watch it
and I know like oh that's what they say
you are we've got a privilege I don't
know I